écoutez bien
nous avons décidé d'occuper la direction
nationale de la npa
avant de montrer au gouvernement qu'il
doit répondre à notre exigence aucun
salarié de chansons npa
cette occupation est pacifique les
salariés qui travaillent à ne sont pas
nos ennemis vous fait si les nouvelles
barges
voici on n'a pas tous et vous graver
dans le marbre louvre et puis c'est tout
vous préférez qu'on casse
[Musique]
recherchez les volailles dans ma forme
s
ouais
[Musique]
très déterminés prêts à rester le temps
qu'il faut le rester longtemps
roland szpirko dans la lutte des
chaussons de l'usiné sont super image il
vous est arrivé vous d'employer cette
méthode mais enfin j'ai une petite
question là où est la violence parce que
là je la vois pas de violence je vois 0
violences massives là où je vois la
violence c'est dans la fermeture de
chansons là je la vois la violence je
vois des milliers de familles ouvrières
qui vont être plongés dans la misère qui
je vois des travailleurs qui ont passé
leur vie qu'ils ont peut-être laissé
leur santé un pur pour chaussons dans et
pour tous pour toutes ses usines je les
vois est remis
être être être être mis dehors quoi et
là c'est de la violence et vous savez
d'ailleurs la picardie l'aisne le nord
regarder cdr industriel regarder cette
misère et cette précarité aujourd'hui
qui est d'une violence mais alors
extrême moi je pense que la première
violence c'est ça c'est la misère c'est
la misère c'est le fait de ne même pas
pouvoir gagner sa vie dans cette société
même pas avoir ce droit là mais là dans
les images dont je vois absolument zéro
violence est par ailleurs moi ça mais
moi ça me ça me fait même même je vais
vous dire ça me fait rêver ça ah oui ils
s'invitent sur à pôle emploi il s'invite
sur les plateaux de télé il s'invite sur
les champs-elysées et moi je pense que
oui les et tous ceux qui sont opprimés
et bien ils doivent s'inviter sans quoi
ce en quoi bon on est voué à être les
éternels sacrifiés on n'existe pas en
fait on est même invisible on est même
invisible donc bah oui voilà faut qu on
s'invite comme j'ai les choses oui comme
les gilet jaune mais j'ai tiré encore
plus que ça parce que moi je pense que
ce mouvement d gilet jaune au moment il
m'a conforté il m'a conforté dans cette
conviction profonde que la capacité de
révolte elle est intacte dans la société
et qu'elle peut venir de femmes et
d'hommes que con qu'on n'imagine pas
qu'on n'imagine pas parce qu'ils ne sont
pas organisés ils n'ont jamais fait de
syndicalisme parce que ils sont jamais
comment dire associé à différents voilà
aux luttes précédentes mais n'empêche
que ils peuvent aussi être amené à se
battre sur ce terrain est à chercher
l'organisation justement mais je pense
enfin moi mon combat par rapport à tout
ça c'est que la lutte elle rentre aussi
dans les entreprises au coeur même du
système dans ces fameuses citadelle
capitaliste là où il ya l'argent qui se
créent mais là aussi où il ya ces
inégalités là où il ya cette souffrance
qui se crée et là où les décisions sont
prises où les décisions sont prises et
parce que c'est c'la devrait
véritablement on aura un levier pour
peser sur la politique de ces
multinationales de cette classe
capitaliste donc voila moi c'est ça ma
politique mais mais oui il faut il faut
forcément se faire une place il faut il
faut utiliser cette force collective
parce que dans les images ce qu'on voit
c'est que si la porte est ouverte au
pied de biche sait qui a quand même ils
sont une cinquantaine ou 60 derrière
vouloir rentrer à pas vouloir se ferme
usa pas vouloir se
a pas accepté un conte les musel
[Musique]